there are lots of questions that are
about how many great circles or how many
small circles can you draw through a
given point here or there
okay so what I want you to do is appeal
back to the diagnosis already gone I'm
going to mess it all up because unity
they'll be very copy of them but maybe
later on for when you're answering these
questions beside your answers when you
say yes you can draw as many as your
life or no you could leave her a single
one you may want to have a diagram like
this example one of the questions is how
many great circles can you draw through
a particular point that you pick
anywhere on the student so if I take a
point here
okay I think it's pretty apparent to
everyone you can draw at least one great
circle right you can draw at least one
so if I'm okay from here directly up to
the center and you play let's make that
the radius of a great circle so I guess
might then do something like this there
you go
so I can put it leap one right but the
thing is if you look carefully you'll
see that you should be able to put a
whole bunch more and in fact there's a
point on the sphere on the surface we
have already ready Illustrated this do
you notice how it could be original two
circles the original two great circles
that I put on there and because they
meet at that spot did you see that and
you've probably got a spot like that on
your sphere as well that's four there
has got two great circles passing
through it and in fact if I kept going I
control more great circles I could draw
one that's often this angle in fact what
this starts to look like is a little bit
like you know in science when they draw
that um that diagram looks kind of like
this to show the electrons fly around
even though they don't actually do that
but you get the idea right you've got a
single point and it's actually going to
be may an infinite number of great
circles that pass through that will
point there I put people drawing water
the diver just becomes a disaster okay
following that they don't ask well what
if I have two points five two points on
the sphere can they pass through
anywhere now I'm going to come back to
human I want to take for example say to
find an Argentine this one- and spot in
colombia here we go okay now you wrap
your two spots I want you to think I
want you to picture a great circle that
passes through both of those so you've
at least got to join digit response and
you also want to pass through the center
of the circle right can you picture
where it is do you see it in your
bye-bye
now would you try it or another one can
you draw another one that's different
and the answer is you can't
whichever one you draw will end up being
exactly the same as the one you started
with okay
now therefore under normal circumstances
and a kill within the Penta to this one
under normal circumstances if you pick
any two points then we get a single
grave circle passing through them but I
again want to make you look back at this
diagram I'm going to redraw it because I
put too much stuff on it
I really draw much to you and then for
one great circle and then I put any
other great Turtles
do you ever we said that that part on
the front where you can see like oh look
they both plants today
look again a tiger you know it says this
guy hiding on the other side right and
look there's more than one great circle
that passes through both of them okay
but these two personal rhythm the rhythm
and for other do they're on they're on
opposite ends exactly yeah so remember
in fact if you come back to this idea
your meridians of longitude what's
special about the Murray is that every
single one is a great circle isn't it
that every single one pass through the
North and South Poles
give two spots okay but you can make
those foes different or another if you
put this one but I say Argentina
officers from Argentina
he is Argentina in South America they're
okay if your opposite either meeting you
get northeast China okay you get this
[ __ ] you up right now that's not the
North and South Pole
it's not the North example but they are
some deals directly opposite to each
other they're still directly opposite
which means you can draw this infinite
number of red circles through them okay
so this is the special case that it's
talking about where your two spots are
exactly opposing each other they could
be the poles or they could be any other
exactly opposite spot a big okay